Léonard
tu ne dois pas te laisser aller comme ça
alors voyons
mais pourquoi Casimir ta Gastine autant
c'est toujours lui qui fait rire les
gens
tu te souviens de notre petit cirque
point monsieur du snobe
[Musique]
pour épater Casimir voilà si je lui fais
des grimaces horrible tu sais comme ça
il faut plus que ça il faut se déguiser
construire un numéro qu'est-ce que tu
voudrais être un clown blanc ou un
Auguste
j'en sais absolument rien
bonsoir dis-moi François est-ce que tu
peux venir tout de suite chez Léonard
non non pas d'explication il
t'expliquera lui-même mais alors apporte
tes accessoires de clown picnico
d'accord
à tout de suite
dites-moi est-ce que vous auriez la
gentillesse de venir avec le facteur
chez Léonard et d'apporter vos
accessoires de clown oui c'est ça merci
à tout de suite
de bonbon Tu seras très bien en
demoiselle du téléphone
parfait maintenant que tu as enfilé le
costume du clown pique Nico et je vais
te poser le faux crâne et la perruque
sur la tête
le nez rouge
pour faire rire Casimir et tous nos amis
qui sont chez eux n'est-ce pas que
Léonard sera drôle comme ça
je n'entends pas grand-chose donc je ne
serai jamais si Casimir rit très fort ou
pas du tout il y a Leonard puisque mon
costume ne te plaît pas
celui de Monsieur du snob ou celui du
facteur ça ira peut-être mieux
il est susceptible alors
mon cher Léonard avec ce costume
pailleté 3 fois trop grand pour toi tu
es sûrement le renard le plus clown est
ce que de les enfants
avec le chapeau du clown blanc monsieur
crème fraîche posé grandement sur ton
crâne comme ceci et ben tu tu es très
bien ah oui mon cher ami je regrette
Léonard porte votre costume
il portera mon chapeau monsieur du snap
vous qui êtes dans le domaine de
l'élégance notre maître à tous vous
devriez voir que votre chapeau ne va pas
avec mon costume
il portera mon chapeau
mon cher ami malgré votre âge certain
vous avez encore beaucoup à apprendre
mais voyons le comble du chic le super
affinement en question vestimentaire
c'est justement de mélanger les effets
qui n'ont pas été créés pour aller
ensemble
avec votre costume Léonard
je vais vous dire ça ne sert à rien de
vous disputer puisque votre chapeau sont
à peu près les mêmes heureusement que ce
soit avec l'un ou avec l'autre je n'y
vois rien ils sont trop grands pour ma
petite tête
je me suis inventé un costume d'un clown
[Rires]
[Musique]
à voile
ma langue au chat
c'est facile monsieur Casimir
vous êtes vraiment sûr de ce que vous
avancez monsieur Leonardo
d'accord alors je vous passe mais
gentiment
mais votre ami Monsieur passe Leonardo
c'est-à-dire moi et ton corps plus drôle
que vous n'est-ce pas François